A celebration of the studio's
100-year animation legacy,
Disney's "Wish" is finally in theaters,
and is a typically charming love letter
to all-things-Disney. Want to know more about
that magical ending? Your wish is our command.
"Wish" begins with a traditional storybook
opening. The narrator starts the tale by
telling the story of Magnifico, the king, and his
queen, Amaya, who founded the kingdom of Rosas.
Magnifico studied magic and was the one person in
Rosas who could grant wishes, so the people give
him their biggest wish on their 18th birthday
with the understanding that they could be
granted by him at some point. In the meantime,
they forget the wish they gave to Magnifico.
Asha, a 17-year-old girl, is interviewing
to be the King's Apprentice. She seems to
impress him until she realizes that
he won't grant most of the wishes,
including her 100-year-old grandfather's,
because he judges them to be too dangerous.
Asha tries to tell her grandfather about what
happened, but because it involves telling him
his wish, he gets upset and tells her she's
excused from the family's dinner table. Asha
runs out of the house and wishes upon a star,
and the star comes down from the sky and starts
granting the animals' and plants' wishes,
including that of Asha's goat, Valentino.
"I'm talking. I am talking. Ha! Who
knew my voice would be this low?"
During this time, Magnifico sees the bright light
of the star and feels threatened. He calls a
meeting to inform the citizens that they should
tell him if they know anything about the light,
and the citizens start questioning him for
the first time. While this is happening,
Asha sneaks up to the king's study to take
back her grandfather and mother's wishes.
Asha heads home and gives
her grandfather's wish back,
but then Magnifico, who has started using
dark magic, appears. He knows she's the
one who wished upon the star and he means to
make her pay. She and her family escape in a
rowboat, but not before he crushes Asha's
mother's wish, making her feel deeply sad.
Magnifico calls another meeting of the
kingdom where he introduces his informant,
Asha's only friend who's over 18, Simon.
He has his wish to be a knight granted,
but then becomes the king's pawn.
Asha, Valentino, and Star return to
the city from the rowboat and join
with her friends to take on the king.
The queen appears and joins them. Asha
leads Magnifico away while the rest of
them go to get their wishes. But when
Magnifico finally catches up with Asha,
it turns out it was Simon in disguise.
Magnifico is still in the castle, and
while Amaya and Asha's friends manage
to gather the wishes with Star's help,
Magnifico captures Star and traps it in
his staff. Asha runs to the castle to stop
this but Magnifico disarms her with magic.
She appeals to the people of Rosas, and as
they make wishes, they overcome Magnifico
and he gets trapped in his own staff. Star is
freed and everyone can now pursue their wishes
as they see fit. Simon apologizes to Asha,
and Asha becomes everyone's fairy godmother.
Asha wishing on a star ended up inspiring
others, and eventually the whole kingdom,
to rise up. It's a compelling statement
about the power that one simple act can
have to convince others to take a stand
and help both themselves and others.
Magnifico seems to be a benevolent king,
so people give him their wishes because,
one, he promises to safeguard them, and two,
because of the possibility that he'll grant
them. In Rosas, people don't wish upon stars,
so in order to have their wish come
true, Magnifico is their only option.
The trouble is that once they give their
wishes to Magnifico, they forget all about
them. This means if there's a possibility that
their wish could be fulfilled through things
like lessons or hard work, they can't pursue
that, because they don't remember their wishes.
For example, Asha's grandfather wants to
inspire people by playing the mandolin, and
through lessons and frequent practice, he could
get good enough to inspire people. But because
he surrendered his wish at 18 and can't remember
it, he's done nothing to pursue his wish since.
While Magnifico tells the people that
giving up their wishes is a great thing,
especially because he might grant them at
some point, in reality, it's a tragedy.
"People come here because they
know they can't make their own
dreams come true. The journey
is too hard. It is too unfair."
Magnifico grants a lot of wishes, but he doesn't
grant everyone's wish, and that is by design.
While there are some acceptable wishes that slip
through the cracks because he simply doesn't get
to them, there are many more that he doesn't
grant because he judges them to be too risky.
For instance, they could promote anarchy or
treason, or they could promote a smear campaign
against Magnifico, or they could do neither
of those things and be completely innocent,
but since Magnifico doesn't know for
sure, he doesn't grant those wishes.
Asha's grandfather is, again, a perfect example.
His desire to inspire people with his mandolin
is deemed too vague to be granted. So
although it's a beautiful wish to Asha,
it has the potential to be sinister
to Magnifico, because he can imagine
a scenario where Asha's grandfather's
music inspires people in negative ways.
Because Magnifico has all the wishes and no one
else can even remember them, he and he alone
has the power to judge each person's wish,
granting only the ones he finds innocuous.
"They deserve more than—"
"I DECIDE WHAT EVERYONE DESERVES!"
Asha is perhaps the only person in Rosas who
would wish upon a star, and it has everything
to do with her father. Her father was deeply
invested in the stars and often took her to a
tree out over the water that allowed them to look
at the stars uninterrupted by the sights of Rosas.
Asha learned from her father that everyone
is connected to the stars and took that
perspective to heart, especially
because he died when she was 12,
making his observations all
the more precious to her.
She wishes upon the star because of her
father saying they're all connected to the
stars. She doesn't expect anything to happen
because of it, and is surprised when it does.
In fact, when she makes her wish, which she states
in the song "This Wish," she simply wants everyone
in Rosas to, quote, "have something more...
than this." More specifically, she wants to
give her grandfather and mother's wishes back
to them, so they can work on them themselves.
She sees this as better than waiting
for them to be granted by Magnifico,
especially because he's already stated that
he will never grant her grandfather's wish.
"Your wish will never be granted!"
When Asha states her wish, the
star she wishes on comes down to
Earth to be by her side as she tries to
right the wrongs of Magnifico. However,
it doesn't grant Asha's wish. Jennifer Lee,
the co-writer of "Wish," told Rotten Tomatoes,
"Star really is all those things that Disney
gives us: hope, possibility, wonder, joy."
"That doesn't tell you the answers, it's
just there for you when you need it."
So Star isn't there to make Asha's
dream come true. It's there, instead,
to offer hope and back her up when she needs it.
This can be seen by the way Star accompanies
Asha when she breaks into Magnifico's study
and takes back her grandfather's wish.
It helps them get out of the locked
elevator to the castle, for example,
by using its magic to unlock the door,
but Asha has to do the heavy lifting of
taking her grandfather's wish herself.
That said, there are times when Star can
make wishes come true. It does this for
many of the animals and plants in the forest,
sprinkling them with stardust so they can talk,
and therefore granting their wishes. Star also
makes the wishes float out of the castle so
the people can reclaim them. So Star does
have the ability to help, to some extent.
In the end, Asha, through her
kindness and selflessness,
has managed to free the whole kingdom from
the tyranny of Magnifico. While Amaya,
the queen, has become the ruler of the
kingdom, Asha is anointed the kingdom's
fairy godmother by Star, who gives her
a wand and robes in a ceremony that is
very much like that in "Cinderella" when
Cinderella gets her gown for the ball.
Asha objects to the new role, which
is exactly why she'll be good at it,
according to her friends. But granting
wishes exactly as a fairy godmother would
makes it seem like she's pretty much replacing
Magnifico, given he was doing the same thing.
Asha promises to be just about it, and that
seems to be enough for the people of Rosas,
but it's hard not to wonder if Asha will stick
to that sentiment. After all, she's only 17,
she has a lot of life to live and the power
to grant wishes has the power to corrupt her,
just like it did Magnifico.
Actors react
Ariana DeBose is excited to be part of "Wish,"
voicing Asha. She's a longtime Disney fan,
so to come to the film that is being put
out as part of Disney's 100th is a special
honor. When asked what audiences can take away
from the film, DeBose told The Nerds of Color,
"In this particular film, to watch this young girl
of color, with braids and freckles, an unlikely
leader, step into her power. It doesn’t mean that
she’s not afraid; she is. And it doesn’t mean that
she doesn’t make mistakes; she does. But to see
how one person can step up to the plate and say,
‘I’m not really sure how I’m going to get my
way through, but I’m going to get through.’"
Chris Pine, like DeBose, was tickled to be
part of "Wish," voicing Magnifico. He was
especially thrilled to be voicing
the villain, telling Kim Holcomb,
"There's humor to it, the guy's a buffoon
[...] I think I like playing characters
that think they're really, really cool and
simply aren't when you get underneath the
hood. It's always fun to play those guys.
Even his hero song, 'This Is the Thanks
I Get' is the most revealing song about
his deep insecurities about being loved."
Pine also had many complimentary
things to say about his co-star and
the chemistry they shared.
Pine told Today's Esquire,
"Working with Ariana was an absolute
delight. She's not only an incredibly
talented performer but also a wonderful
person. Our chemistry on set translated
seamlessly onto the screen, and
I'm grateful for the experience."
Jennifer Lee has been part of some
of the greatest animated films of the
last fifteen years, including "Frozen,"
which she co-directed. She also co-wrote
the screenplay for "Wish," and spoke
about Asha to Rotten Tomatoes, saying,
"We were talking about Asha and knowing we
wanted that moment as a teenager where you're
living your life, everything's fine,
and then all the sudden you're like,
'Hey, that's not right.' And I
always say it's a very generous
time. Teenagers are the ones who want
to make the world better for others."
"We give them a bad rap sometimes,
that they're selfish, and I'm like,
'They're the ones who can see a better world."
Peter Del Veccho, a veteran
producer of Disney animated films,
has a lot to say about the
villain, telling Comicbook.com,
"Disney villains have evolved over
time, and some villains are revealed,
but there's something delicious about
knowing that someone's the villain from
the beginning. What makes this one
unique is he's also charming and
charismatic and you actually watch him
evolve as more pressure is put on him."